hello everyone my name is Philippe for
me Associate Producer on far cry 5 and
I'm Mari cañedo a scriptwriter on far
cry 5 today we're gonna take you through
our extended III demo and highlight some
of the features that were really excited
about
welcome to hope County Montana this is
the Holland Valley a section of farmland
that the project it means gate is using
as their breadbasket with us in this
demo we have our loyal dog boomer as
you're thankful higher for now I just
can't resist the set up is too perfect
I'm going to use this tractor against
the cult the cult is stealing supplies
and kidnapping people using them to
prepare for a doom say that's really
just around the corner we're gonna put
you in the shoes of a rookie deputy and
drop you into the heat of the conflict
in Fargo flies we want to give you tools
that feel like they belong in Montana
and your fight against a doomsday
call-out
and now we're going to make a quick
getaway in case reinforcements arrive
boomer is just one of the many allies
you can recruit using our for hire
system each of them has special
abilities and it's up to you to select
which companion to bring along for the
ride
whether you're just exploring the open
world or fighting cultists head-on in a
specific location cute dog my dad would
love to know what type of breed is
boomer no seriously his breed is mutt
but he is mostly blue heeler by the
looks of him Montana is a great place to
fish and it was important for us to
create a system where we allow players
to live that experience in the rivers
and lakes of Hoke County you will find
many different types of fish it's a
really good way for players to gain
experience and also just get away from
the conflict
here we see the player needs to fight a
little bit to get the fish nice catch of
the day on the menu so it's nice to
unwind with some fishing every now and
then but we know the called isn't taking
any breaks because they have an
apocalypse to prepare for as you explore
the county you'll come across cultists
working hard to serve Joseph the father
of their cult they're taking food and
supplies for their bunkers they're
blocking the roads so no one can escape
and they're destroying resources so the
resistance can't use them and it looks
like we spotted something up ahead you
know let's take out our binoculars
alright seems like there's a small group
of cultist there mari alright so this
looks like a forced baptism what do you
say we get in there Phil now let's do it
I think the best approach would be to go
in stealthily through the river with
boomer by our side I think we're well
equipped to get rid of those two guys
here we're using one of the new iconic
weapons featured in Far Cry 5 the
revolver and you'll be able to customize
those weapons by adding attachments or
changing the color scheme and hunt their
cult in style alright when we're showing
off one of these one of his skills this
can really be a game changer in a fight
where you're a bit low of ammo or you
don't have the right weapon for the
situation he's a good dog
you know boomers a great all-rounder who
can support any playstyle
even without your commands he'll fetch
guns for you take down cultists in a
fight and he'll tag enemies and animals
from far away with his keen sense of
smell the game being said in America it
was important for us to bring a wide
variety of vehicles from pickups the
tractors to big rigs like this one this
one is specifically called the
Widowmaker it's like a battering ram on
wheels as a great tool to create chaos
and take down enemy vehicles or road
blocks it looks like we got one here
let's do it that boss bobblehead didn't
even move we're so good I got him glued
onto the dash I said
so it sounds like we're listening to the
cult radio station I gotta say some of
their hymns are pretty catchy Phil
and we're pulling up to Ryan Sons
aviation this is the home of Nick Wray
he's a crop duster and a family man he's
doing what he can to keep his family
safe and keep the Colt from getting his
plane but it looks like they've beaten
us here so let's jump right in there's
no time to waste
let's Boomer like kind of create
distraction for us to get behind cover
and help Nick fly the Cultus in fire
fire five you'll need to improvise and
choose from a vast arsenal of weapons
and find elements in the environment to
take down the enemy there you go so we
just took down the last Cultus at Nick
rise using my favorite stealth weapon a
baseball bat sometimes you can hear
boomer growling when you feel the threat
nearby and boomer is just part of far
cry 5 living world we've built where
there's always something or someone
around you whether you notice it or not
this means you'll always need to be
prepared
[Music]
boomer will stand his ground and defend
you from predators as there are a lot of
moments for the player to hunt or be
hunted and we've built a deep ecosystem
that represents Montana's wilderness so
you know we've seen ducks a sturgeon
deer and this is just a small sample of
all of the wild animals that you'll
encounter in Hope County so now we've
jumped into Nick Ryze plane it's been in
his family for generations and with it
we'll take to the sky to destroy some
cult silos that are hoarding explosives
the world that we've built is larger
than any far cry before and for the
first time you can explore the world in
any direction that you choose right from
the start
in this demo we're in Holland Valley and
this is just one small part of hope
County Montana is called Big Sky Country
after all flying is a great way to
travel explore the county and scout out
new opportunities and also close things
up Oh looks like the cult has decided to
intervene that plane belongs to a chosen
now the chosen are elite soldiers and
it's their job to basically crush any
threat to the project that even skates
so we've done enough to anger the cult
we're gonna engage a little dogfight
with them and show them what we think of
them that's right even in the air
there's a lot of opportunities for the
players to you know find or discover or
get chased by vice pretenders coverage
yeah totally a hunt or be hunted as we
call it
I think right now we are the predator
yeah I got them on the run you're
smoking
and we did it well done so thanks for
watching and we're really looking
forward to showing you more thank you
[Music]
you